[музика]
виталий я макколам анька вчитель школи
крила продовжуємо курс
алгебри 9 класу сьогодні у нас стікала
тема називається маніпуляції це пічну
інформації
[музика]
ми хіба вона йому різанини в папці отрута можна
подавати інформацію графічного в такому
ви люди вику мої і облава що відразу мід
і обірвана лобі та честь інтерес треба
далі ми проходили основні види подачі
графічної інформації
графіки та діаграми
з приклад сток часто діаграми обидва
інакше називається гістограма та
кругова діаграма на крові на колі
відео рамі ми видим сектори та частка
шкіряна величина зображається в нічний
сектор хочу вам показати і ось так і
приклад до волі немає балів інформації
складай не поважають
назва жінка тайяки тут написи падре
тинацу не будь то кругових діаграм поні
ваш кайт синій ти яку частку займають
дуже США категорії впш черв'яки
вся діаграма кругового на бочку і
петьку там боротьба ніж про неї за три ви
мирним ефектом ми про такі діаграми
сьогодні поговоримо про деталь ніші справа
це по ній за раз відразу метану приклад
вузька криза
видозмінюється частка категорії, наприклад
android та частки категорія blackberry os
ще тиковий приклад знаєш таки не так
важливіше за інформацію тут подана
мою на базі ці категорії розгадаєте та
коли слід не підведіть на подачу на
графічному поданні інформації
діаграми ми по чиєму по
адже сотках шістдесят один вид соток
maeva le date і майже
я в 2 тибет фініш 35 років сотки алла за
графіку за діаграму ми чому ще
візуально винограду я у декаль гарний
45 бразивши бейт-шемеш помаранчевий
почутті на чому такий ефект наш по
старого йому так але ефект об'ємного ви
ви світу
і через c здаєте ще за велично
займаючи на брата більше разом давайте
розрядом у вас такий простий приклад
який у нас є
на графіку дві величини 1 ви особисто
значення 2 а інша валочно
значення честь а тепер уразлива ніж
ці величини
справжнього вигляду стоп чеки таких
тоненьких
а у вигляди плоть на прихід квадраті
дробового квадрати у цих ребро буде
таке ж мусить і
і акція величина ось in квадрат травня
ребро
2 сторони два сантиметри обидва
2 1 ці вінчі квадрат травня бік честь
за плащем, бо чим ще вин на брата
більшої ніш квадраті стороною 2 менше
ніш утричі у нас правді з курсу
геометрії
ви можете пару кого ти ви знижка розвинув
площа такого квадрата більше загадайте
я хочу коефіцієнт видно що не було
квадрату до маленького
3 то площі дражнитися
ось як квадрат розлив води разить
від і докладний мощей гершер з пробуємо
подачу інформації у вигляди кубів top to
pray вдома до об'ємної подачі інформації
на графік, а йому бочку на екрані нас
правді колими даємо овочевий кусь
інфографіку на екрані ми з однією бо чим
у вдови мирному просторі і можна його
трави мирний вигляд на брата
найкрасивішого ворожить али інформацію вин з
подвір'я давайте дробмаш цех квадраті
куби до доїдемо до додому їм трофі
об'ємності
а еквадор, що спостерігається, чорт тебе в
ночі на зустрічі більше незвично і на вигляд
на f9 разит
з курсовими три пісні шиви буде
проходить і я
відрі знаєте обсяги подібних tell у
просторі
я качок у think загинув насті 3
то обсяг тивате лабуда берша в
до в кубі в третьому степані top to thrive
третьому степану
у 27 разів обсяг куба буду більшим
лише об'єм тіла маленького куба він же з
об'ємним та діаграмами навіть складно
візуально розібралися а чим ми бачимо на
інфографіки
і часто дати його методу до тіла методу
вдаються а deepcool та
потрібно я просто почну вийти на дати
у парі мене не за нашими личинами навіки
все якуба що тут змінити менше
двічі подаємо ще такі графіки
тому діаграм інформація про стандарт
економії порожнього в америці отрута мета
стандарт змінився за 78 уроку по 85 рік
навіть ті кого можна його на красиво
поданої інформації на відразу іншого
нам за собі масової інформації подарувати
ще тут маємо на 1978 світі ми бачимо
число 18 18 миль на 1 галон порожнього так
той сівби починав я до та вимірювати як
побачите прямо та приїжджають через
стандартам автомобіль на одному обсязі
впав його на обсязі 1 галон вісімнадцять
миль за розвитком технології
збилися економічність і ми бачимо
новий стандарт у kenshi 85 рік
автомобіль травня приїжджати та 27 половиною
миль на одному галоні полого подавився у
скільки разів
відрі
знявся величина в числах і візуально
числах 27 сили та 1 друга в парі мене не
18g видно вже не по числах приблизно
1 тіла п'ятдесят три сотих приблизно 2
рази і видозмінюються стандарт але як на
графіку справжності інформації повинен
ви dressta щоб означаючи стандартно 1978
рік 0,6 дюйма
дітей роздайте бачиться вона була на
такого на 0,7 дюйма винен а вид ризику
на 1985 5,3 дюйми у справах в одного
почну на і ну ось remy ma коефіцієнт
приблизно 8,30
подаруйте у скільки разил
інформацію було подано неправильно вузьким
гарно на викроюю на вісь такі
приклади недостовірно про іскру йому так
uman давай інформації можна пробитися
через графіки та діаграми
давайте розрядом а ще так і приклад чим
може бути хірша нижче трави мирній траві
мирно даху діаграма обидва інформацію
виглядає 3 ви мирних стоп чики-чики США
можна буде інформації подано ви заради
трави мирних пірамідок абакана лютий вона
ще більше ви кремлі дальні кен ієна
графіку подаруйте б дошка хлопець реально
таблиця
лівого боку обидва не таблиці
преміальний графік лівої сторони
субсидій на рівні стовбур різних видів їй
а на колоді своїй у Різдва різьблених
підемо харчування подано на прикол
на м'ясо та молочну продукцію 73
сотки
сімдесят чотири сотні субсидії а в
праві частини ним і чому так вже
діаграму ще покази з проживання
рекламодавець dos побажання у port
венозний портик, наприклад
зерна we з трави в 12 порцій
на 11 зернових strap і парадів животи 9
штраф за фрукти та овочі та чисть straw
про партійного шукаємо місце та протеїни ясу
молочку і так далі з графік хоче
показати наскільки велика різниця між
субсидіями та рекомендованими порціями
давайте подаємо з на цедру та графіка джим
і майем біля вежі та часті на піраміди
6 порцій царя дня годинник на піраміди 9
партій та нижні частини на піраміди 11
партії сказати у вас падаєте вираз у
верхньої частини на піраміди коричного
дійство складу я більше половини
вид жовтої нижньої частини на напруження та
купа нас проводиться так 9 числа 6 менше
адже половини числа в 12 на графіку
чому коричного частини ну в діяч
корозії цим у 10 разів менше нам заєць
синьо-жовто чистим помив до
обидва можна в с драббла на розум з ну ще
висота шкірного
кулі шкірного прошивку дієвості 6 до
9 до 11
олег ми з вам ще й на роз'їдав і я до
чому так і йому об'ємність початку
площі потім обсяг то інформація
викроюється найсильніший із найсильніших
cool його розгадає діаграми графіки
заходь
бутіку інфографікою до подаєш пом'ятої ти
про ті правила інше тонн
ось пропадаю вам такі тиковий парадокс
називається парадокс симпсону
ви бачите собі таку ситуацію в мер
Сімпсон ви вирішивши зайнятися своїм
здоров'ям та
влада в цій шубі шкірної пробіжки
піновий вирішив роздрукуй у нього пак
масштабу добра а чому ви вирішили раз
патча ти бігати і в піший місяць кожен
день по 5 кілометрів доступного місяця
вінс більше в норму і ви вирішувати бігати і
майже кілометр і став почитати себе
краще дура віші інші місяць третій
місяць же 7 кілометрів висимо 9 10
mrs знаходити коробку за пончиками все та
з'їдаючи від чого ти себе верши
проста займатися спортом і деколь
місяців пару місяців не займаються
пробіжками потім за радіючи і все-таки
хоче займатися спортом хоче поправити
своє здоров'я починаючи пробіжки на жадібний
можемо почитати , кілометрів ще дня
починаючи з одного кілометра ща дня 8
місяць із двох кілометрів на доступний
місяць і так далі але бачимо що на кожному
етапі я до чого програму лінію до військового
кільки з кілометри надінь на початку
руку і в kenshi руку у великому
позитивний позитивну тенденцію вин
збила
киргиз кілометрі якосч вже ми б там
розвідати і середньому кільки з кілометром
вікулін дня, що пробігав у персії
половині руку і кирки стилометрія queen
вибираю сьогодні в другій половині рогу
там йому допомогти вашого починаючи з меншою
ті хтось тенденція і d на зниження з
таким чином
можна подати інформацію так я терміново
люди якогось тур
вологості крученого я десь льону
розгадаєте в папці, а тепер
хочеш вам за про подавати виду йти до v
віці ви зможете дізнаємося це є ще з
диким і прикладами я за такої інформації
легко ввести в аман ніби ск
вирубних зубною пастою створ g що його
продукт означає більше нальоту не джгутика
інша пост
равликів заповнюючи зараз самий його
програма стулок на і більше робітників
місць ми на пранні свій клаптик і такі
пари більше не в рекламі то кулі тис і
що в нас знову якась жадібних, червоний
оксиду випадку років вірджинія чоловіка
давайте графіком отже графік ціни просто
собою 100 думка win with загрожуючи
конкретні числа їх теж можна завантажити з
ними
однак ви є з ну і джамала
способі введення в ману та v2 роті та
маніпуляції за допомогою графіки в hd та
герича на я кислить згорнутий і дороги
та рекламі 1990 іншого уроку компанія
chevrolet
заявив про розчин аня на і знайди ніші
іван точилка ви хрестову вчитися і
графіт винний лаша показуєш 98
адже сотки у всіх вантач не міг
chevrolet та проданих за астані 10 руки
у досі їздять дорогами та алей справляючи
вирази не бували у 2 china день ще
не жбан точилка тойота так і е hd quinny
подивитись у найважливіші над числа лего
струмки і на виду що показаних для
тойота становить про блешня дев'яносто
адже шість з половиною сотки тяжко лава
куплю і Данило ще
між вино 105 мото ставить сотками нібито
банами стелла значення вид 0 доставити
добу а то графік міг би так і вигляд
знаю ширше нижчих способі вас під
вороні даних через маніпуляції з
масштабом з великими та виділення на
великої джастін і осі у пари більше років
пам'ятну віями лікарям із чопа ревну
тебе особливо його мангові і я histogram і
а скільком і пропускаємо їх через нитки в
розмірах стовп пропорції на їхньому
значенням проти масштаб може spotware
в офісі та вздовж осі x
я до провалу в лінійчастих діаграмах я
кевін загрожують його краще ну що зміниться
з джоссом
вся діаграма що показує зростання вони
обидва зарубайте в США з 2008 по 2010 рік
маніпулюючи вісю x двома способами
татка шкала тут на рівно мирно від 15
місячний intervals березні 2009 ст is
not a так що млинець видавався коротшим
мниш по передній 6 місяців використання
правильні шкали для тих даних дає
су картину з коротше не робочих місць до
кінсі 2009 року та і кочовим чикаго що
було доручено зростання б зарубайте
години ваш кола пожинає все відразу після
найбільший є годинник у великій депресії
фінансові щури в США такі прийоми
видами нібито berkova демонстрація фактів
годинний інтервал можна перебрати і так
щоб вимкнути його пливу важливій випаді і
яківець голосі відразу одружена і тихо
інтервалу with beer пивних точок даних
може вистачати важливі зради в
пробіжках між ними на виток що всі
хараста з самим графіком ви краще не
Значних даних можна сформувати їх ібн
і у яблуні мета графік що
і люстру і все вічно гель пензля для дачі
у super bowl справляючи вираз не б
популярності піди і пасті і але заростаючи
to win євро hові приросту населення
рейтингу фактично завищилася а
низовинними отже хоч кілька з любителем
футболу доросла їх не just cause кальней
аудиторії не і наріжте графік нічого
вам не по роках і текст що ви не розумієте
це зусилля суті поданих даних про
б два на ступні графіку ви хрестовий
одні й ті самі дані про температуру
океану національних центрів інформації
про нас кілочки середовища те що у дружини
справляють простягнеш не вирази перший
графік показує середню мову на
температуру ока вона з 1882 по 2016 рукою
показують she's mine та температури не
значними нас правді просто ненавидь
наспів градуса за цельсієм може протягне
і масштабніше екологічніше на зливки про що
у друга діаграмою а до показу і with
heel лінивець середню температуру з чирок
у майя
важливі лише значення заправленого
використання графіки може допомогти нам
інтуїтивно у всіх ну ти доладний
інформацію по скільки сьогодні ви просто
не графіки стала дошкою простим з
виробило та будинку коректного obon edge та
знову використання такого способу
дальня інформація теж доступного разу
cool & david m і тис на графік не
піддавайтеся apple явищ то кривих по
гляньте на піт паз та цифри
шкалу та контекст hd бутіків тис а яку
історію на мага і tirus povestea вам
графік
клімату інформацію можна подавати і ви
заради графіки та діаграми янкул
інформацію візуально подають на
картах я хочу вас познайомити з одним
снайпер ших випад ляльки інформації було
подано на карті говори фіч ней і колір
дужек могло між кальцієм лондону в 1854
уроки на одразу в одному з районі
лондон була епідемія холери і тупим
акти в тему сміх джон сноу не те ще
захищав первинності на літр джон сноу
разом лондон патч 1 ніс і ти на карту
лондону та клубу що з лівого боку по
годині але висновок і будемо килики квн
рей приховував випадки холери, що нас брали
перетворилися на занепад ви можете по
бачати у праві частини не зараз на карту
за тими самими відмітками та нанесеними в
ти самих місцях вен побачиш ще з
купчинь а випадки
клер і перебуваєте до школи днів у вулиці
брід-стріт
на ті його вулиці з знаходимося знаходився
колонка столітті жителі набрали у воду сама
tea кулон до було жерлом жилом клер таким
чином ланцюг один снайпер крок у занепаді
акули
інфографіка нанесено на карту ти допомогла
were to wait і багато ж тип на тему з я
б вам зал wow
їжа на ступнях урок
[музика]
ну